fortsetzung beiden brüder in deutschland
weil es so gut kennen hier die gastgeber
setzen treffen es an diesem tag im
rathaus von kiew sind der tag hat
begonnen nach der anreise mit einem
besuch im stadtteil
der ja mit botschaft zusammen alle
wirklich traurige bekanntheit in der
ganzen welt bekommen hat durch die
furchtbaren verbrechen die dort an der
zivilbevölkerung
russisch aufregend worden sind ich bin
wirklich
vollkommen erschüttert gewesen ich bin
es immer noch diese bilder gehen auch
nicht mehr aus dem kopf sieht was die
zerstörung stattgefunden hat
kulturzentrum kindergärten kirchen
krankenhäuser völlig sinnlos und wahllos
auf die zivilbevölkerung geschossen
worden ist angegriffen
schwere waffen
so was kann man nicht im fernsehen an
gesehen das mich noch mal gesehen haben
um die ganze tragik auch solche angriffe
zu erfassen ich bin dankbar dass ich
heute im lauf des tages gelegenheit
hatte mit
den repräsentanten dieses landes zu
sprechen mit dem parlamentspräsidenten
der mich eingeladen hat aber auch mit
dem ministerpräsidenten mit dem
staatsbesuch zum schluss mit und
bürgermeister dieser stadt ich fühle
mich in der entscheidung die wir in der
letzten woche im deutschen bundestag
getroffen haben er bestätigt dass in
diesem land helfen ich habe große
dankbarkeit erfahren heute für die
initiative der cdu csu fraktion und dann
auch den gemeinsamen beschluss im
deutschen bundestag den wir im letzten
donnerstag getroffen haben mit der
regierung zusammen dass wir diesem land
auch weiter mit waffen saison bestimmt
das ist eine schreckliche lage aber es
ist auch keine einfache
ich hab hier stehen noch mehr als letzte
woche auch im angesichts dieses
schrecklichen krieges dazu dass wir eine
solche entscheidung getroffen haben das
war richtig und wir müssen diesen an
weiterhelfen und der bundeskanzler hat
recht mit seinem board dass hier nicht
nur das territorium der ukraine
geschützte das alleine wirkung noch
grund genug ist zu tun aber wir schützen
und verteidigen ja auch unsere
demokratie unsere freiheit so wie wir
leben auch in deutschland insofern
fühlen wir uns hier mit diesem land sehr
verbunden auch emotional sehr verbunden
den menschen im land also ich bin
wirklich dankbar dass ich die
gelegenheit hatte diesen tag hier heute
in kiel führt zu verbringen und wir alle
hoffen die mich begleiten auf diesem weg
auch noch im minus gelegen weil ich
diese wetter wir alle hoffen dass die
wirklich wirklich bald zu ende ist es
dass wir auf das was wir tun also
beitrag dazu leisten dass er bald zu
ende ist und insofern also einen tag der
schirms nachdenklich macht aber der auch
mit vielen eindrücken für die müssen
mich mit nach hause nehmen nach
deutschland nehmen
was nehmen sie denn von den gesprächen
exzellenz geben nicht nach hause vor
allem gehindert in die gespräche auf und
demonstriert
wir haben ein sehr ausführliches sehr
langes gespräch geführt
dort waren
ich habe verabredet dass ich die details
dieses gespräches zunächst aber dem
bundesplatz wieder geben bevor ich das
öffentliche aussage mit der anklage
verständnis dass ich mich an die
verabredung auge behalten möchte ich
werde nach meiner und kenne
bundeskanzler gespräch natürlich
informieren das verbindet das mit viel
hoffnung dass helfen und dass wir auch
bei dieser hilfe bleiben so viel gar
nicht sagen und es war ausgesprochen
gespräch also sehr und so was für eine
botschaft mitgebracht ich war so was
jetzt haben sie erkannt
der besuch dazu beitrage dass in
deutschland sowie in der bundesregierung
geleistet wird
wir haben ja in der letzten woche schon
aber gezeigt dass auch das parlament
etwas leisten kann hier nicht allein auf
die bundesregierung hier stützt sind
wir werden mehrere themen in den
nächsten wochen monaten neben dem
aktuellen kriegsgeschehen wenn es
natürlich auch die frage sein was machen
wir der kleine in der europäischen
perspektive da steht die frage im raum
ob die
ein beitritt status bekommt und auch
mitglied der europäischen union werden
perspektive werden zu wollen ich
befürworte dass er da steht die frage im
raum wie hälfte diesem land denn auch in
den wiederaufbau der eines tages ansteht
und vor allem steht die frage war dass
der krieg zu ende und was muss nur nach
dem krieg für verträgen schließen und da
gibt es natürlich den wunsch der ukraine
auch garantie wenn stütze haben da muss
deutschland eine führende rolle spielen
die auch deutschland eine führende rolle
spielen muss bei der frage der aufnahme
in die europäische union emi ist das
heute noch mal so deutlich geworden dass
wird immer deutlicher dann auch mal
außerhalb des eigenen ländern das ist
auf diesem land auf unserem land um
viele hoffnungen und das wird am samstag
bei diesen gesprächen noch mal deutlich
deutschland muss eine starke rolle eine
führungsrolle dieser europäischen union
übernehmen und das ist mir heute noch
mal so eindrücklich klar geworden auch
in allen gesprächen die hier geführt
haben übrigens auch mit
oppositionspolitikern dient das auch
beide gesagt haben der frühere präsident
branko die moschee so beide gesagt haben
ihr ist eine starke rolle frage es gab
beim abgesagten steinmeier für ein
bisschen hat hat er quasi wo der
abgesagt oder andere richtig angebracht
und in erfahrung bringen können ob erst
einmal gekommen
wir haben darüber gesprochen
sehen sie es mir nach dass ich das nicht
mehr öffentlich aufgeklärt ist es
glücklich
bundeskanzler als leberwurst verzeichnen
ich finde wir sollten jetzt mal
rhetorisch
wir versuchen auf ein niveau kommen uns
die gegenseitigen hilfe nicht unnötig
stören so und ich werde natürlich auch
mit dem ukrainischen botschafter in
berlin sprechen wir nicht zurück wird
übrigens bei der verbreitung dieses
system geholfen hat aber ich wünschte
mir dass die sprache auch gut so